Sometimes I get hate mail and when we have
that hate mail read by a professional voiceover
artist, we call it hatriot mail.
Here's a quick reminder about that.
Why don't you take some hydroxyl chloroquine
for that Trump derangement syndrome, teary
eyed man written by patriots who hate David
Pakman because of America and because freedom.
All right, let's get.
There's a lot.
I'm warning you, I would get the kids out
of the room.
There's a lot in this week's Hatriot Mail.
Take a listen to this park, man.
You're the most disingenuous piece of it on
all of you.
Go yourself.
David Pakman.
Call me prostitution.
Pattie's loser.
David Pakman douche boy to be anti Catholic,
anti-American leftist cannot tell the difference
between one hundred percent male in my voter
role and ask for a mail in ballot votes.
My God, how stupid are the lefties dogs.
Most damaging interview.
What a clown loser is pompous jerk is so a
lot being said here and a lot of it is just
wrong.
You might be surprised to hear.
Maybe not.
I am certainly not a communist.
You know, this is one of the funny things.
It's actually similar to what's going on with
Joe Biden, where with Joe Biden, you have
some on the left who are furious that Joe
Biden is not a socialist.
And then you have much of the right attacking
Joe Biden for being a socialist or a Marxist
or an anarchist or a communist or whatever
the case may be.
In that same way, there is a whole contingent
of the Internet left that doesn't like me.
They don't think I am left enough because
I am not a socialist.
And then at the same time, one of the most
common attacks we get from hatriot is you
communists, socialist, Marxist, David Pakman.
The truth is, I'm just a social Democrat.
That that that's the very boring reality.
I'm certainly not anti Catholic.
I'm not anti-American.
But what what the hatriot does get right is
that I am an American leftist.
That's true.
And this is a Trump voter.
And, you know, we I keep getting calls from
people saying, how can I convince my Trump
supporting friend, my Trump supporting cousin
might Trump supporting parents to vote for
Joe Biden.
I don't believe you can.
That hatriot male is from a devout Trump list.
There is no point in arguing with them and
trying to convince them.
With eight weeks minus a few days to go before
the election to change their vote.
They don't care about facts.
They don't care about logic.
Just get the vote out from people who are
on our side.
We are better off.
We are more likely to have an impact.
It is far easier to convince people who already
agree with us that they should vote than it
is to argue with someone like that and say,
no, you're wrong about Trump.
You should vote for Biden.
It's an exercise in futility.
It's an exercise in frustration.
What's not an exercise in futility is using
the coupon code Hatriot 40.
Whenever you sign up at join Pacman dot com.
You will save 40 percent off of the membership
of your choice with the coupon code hatriot
40.
And when that code is used, I have it on good
authority that Harriet's cry.
They can't handle it.
I join Pacman dot com coupon code Hatriot
40.